mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour c'est par le conseil des
ministres que nous ouvrirons aujourd'hui
la présente édition de télé midi un
conseil des ministres qui se réunira
exceptionnellement cet après midi au
palais de l'elysée sous la présidence de
monsieur georges pompidou trois exposés
sont attendus cet après-midi un tour
d'horizon de la situation internationale
par monsieur maurice schumann le bilan
de la session parlementaire de printemps
par monsieur roger frey enfin monsieur
valéry giscard d'estaing présentera au
conseil les grandes masses budgétaires
pour 1971 alors françois henri de virieu
j'aimerais que l'on revienne sur cet
exposé de monsieur valéry giscard
d'estaing
oui il faut d'abord ce qu'est ce qu'il
faut dire des passionnés que la première
partie du budget qui viendra en
discussion
cet après midi aux côtés du ministre
avec le budget se prépare à deux temps
dans un premier temps on voit ce qu'il
faudrait dépenser pour faire marcher le
pays et pour appliquer la politique
définie par le gouvernement et dans un
second temps mais cela se passe
seulement au mois de septembre on voit
par quelle recette on pourrait couvrir
ses dépenses donc pour l'instant on en
est qu'à la première phase celle des
dépenses
le conseil des ministres à peau de cet
après-midi approuvera ce que l'on
appelle les grandes masses c'est à dire
que le président de la république
lui-même dira à chaque ministre ce qu'il
est autorisé à dépenser en 1971 pour son
département comme chaque année les
ministres dépensiers sont montrés
gourmands cette année le total de leurs
demandes atteint 181 2 milliards de
francs c'est à dire 14% de plus que le
budget de l'année en cours qui lui n'a
pas dépassé si l'on peut dire
160 milliards alors bien sûr chacun
estime qu'il a de bonnes armes de bonnes
raisons de dépenser de l'argent le
ministère de l'éducation nationale parce
qu'il faut faire plus d'école le
ministère le ministre de l'equipement
parce qu'il faut entretenir les routes
mais monsieur giscard d'estaing lui ne
l'a pas entendu de cette oreille ils
estiment qu'il est malsain dans un pays
que l'état que les progrès ce que les
dépenses de l'état progressent plus vite
que la richesse générale du pays et
c'est pourquoi il a réussi à faire
triompher le point de vue selon laquelle
les dépenses de l'état ne devrait pas
cette année progresser de plus de 7 à 8%
entre 1970 et 1971 alors on a rogné les
demandes de crédit ministre dépensier
dans des arbitrages qui ont été rendus
par messieurs chaban delmas
et cet après midi restera en
on va faire une dernière toilette et à
descendre dans corps doigts ou 2
milliards bien monsieur giscard
d'estaing avait déjà parlé hier je crois
devant le conseil économique et social
oui alors monsieur giscard d'estaing
avait expliqué hier qu'elle serait alors
là on retombe dans le court terme et
qu'elle serait la politique économique
de la france au cours du second semestre
il a été formel il a dit le redressement
commencé en septembre dernier au
lendemain de la dévaluation est terminé
il est terminée parce qu'il a été réussi
bien sûr on ne sortira que
progressivement du plan de redressement
mais d'ores et déjà il faut mettre en
place une autre politique économique
destiné à relancer l'activité en france
une activité qui donne d'ailleurs
actuellement quelques signes
d'essoufflement d'essoufflement et je
voudrais préciser en parenthèse que
demain les dirigeants du patronat ce
combat est reçu à ce propos par monsieur
chaban-delmas auxquels ils exprimeront
leurs doléances
monsieur giscard d'estaing a annoncé
hier aux conseillers économiques que
l'état pour sa part participerait à cet
effort de relance économique
il va débloquer de l'argent qui est
actuellement bloquée dans un tiroir
budgétaire qui s'appelle le fonds
d'actions conjoncturelle une partie des
milliards qui vont être ainsi débloqué
serviront à relancer l'activité
économique en passant des commandes dans
le secteur des travaux publics notamment
dans les régions en difficulté
- est-ce que vous voyez autre chose à
signaler pour ce conseil des ministres
cet après midi oui il a il ya d'abord un
petit texte une série de textes qui
concerne la législation des importations
pétrolières qu'il s'agit d' adapter aux
exigences du marché commun et puis on se
demande aussi si monsieur pompidou ne
choisira pas de dire quelques mots d'un
sujet qui lui tient à coeur
il souhaiterait en effet que les petites
communes ne soit plus aussi tenus en
laisse si l'on peut dire par les préfets
qu'elles le sont actuellement
et notamment il souhaiterait que l'on
renonce à l'obligation d'un feu vert
préalable du préfet sur les budgets des
communes avant que les maires ne puisse
commencer engager les dépenses bien
merci françois henri de virieu aussi le
conseil des ministres se réunit cet
après midi il se réunit vous le savez
d'habitude le matin c'est en raison de
la visite officielle en france du
président bongo
le chef de l'état gabonais a entrepris
ce matin un voyage en province voyage
qui le conduira successivement halak et
ensuite à pierrelatte mais revenons si
vous le voulez bien
en arrière hier soir le président et
madame bongo au fret au quai d'orsay un
grand dîner en l'honneur du président et
de madame georges pompidou un
commentaire de stéphane peu auparavant
le président bongo s'était rendu à
l'elysée la construction d'une ligne de
chemin de fer la création d'un premier
cycle de l'enseignement supérieur à
libreville et enfin l'amélioration de la
couverture radiophonique du gabon tels
ont été les trois thèmes principaux des
entretiens approfondis qui a eu le
président de la république du gabon avec
monsieur pompidou et les membres du
gouvernement français dans la soirée le
président et madame albert bernard bongo
ont offert un grand dîner au ministère
des affaires étrangères où il réside en
l'honneur du président de la république
française et le madame pompidou
de nombreuses personnalités du
gouvernement français assisté à ce dîner
à l'issue duquel monsieur bongo à
remercier monsieur pompidou de l'intérêt
qu'ils avaient manifesté au problème
gabonais monsieur pompidou a répondu en
se félicitant de la cordialité des
entretiens qu'il avait eus avec le
président gabonais autre visiteur de
marque attendus cet après midi au palais
de l'elysée le président de la
république malgache
monsieur philibert tirant dans le
domaine économique et social
on reparle aujourd'hui encore de
l'aéroport d'orly le conflit avec les
aiguilleurs du ciel du ciel vous le
savez n'est pas encore réglé il faudra
attendre le 15 juillet pour que les
organisations professionnelles donnent
leur accord pour la signature d'un
projet peut-être avec le ministre des
transports par intérim monsieur galles
depuis hier soir une nouvelle grève
affecte orly c'est celle des bagagistes
et des manutentionnaires pour savoir
quelles sont les conséquences de cette
grève notamment pour les passagers
christian barqui sur s'est rendu ce
matin à orly regardez ce qu'il a
rapporté il fallait attendre parfois
plus de deux heures hier soir pour
récupérer ses bagages à orly depuis la
situation est redevenue normale
la compagnie air france a annulé 50% de
ses vols européens est métropolitain et
à engager des bagagistes de remplacement
tous les vols long courriers sont
assurés
cette grève des bagagistes d'air france
avait commencé brusquement
hier vers 16 heures les raisons de cette
grève les 800 agents bagagistes
réclament une prime double
non accident et une augmentation des
effectifs en revanche à air inter
situation normale tous les vols prévus
seront assurés parmi les passagers qui
attendaient sans doute ce matin à orly
il y en avait certains qui étaient sans
doute plus impatients que les autres je
veux parler de ses 3000 américains qui
effectuera une tournée dans les
principales capitales européennes et qui
ont appris pendant cette tournée que
l'organisation de voyages qui leur avait
fourni ce voyage est bien cette
organisation avait fait faillite
rassurez vous ces passagers avaient
quand même leur billet de retour en
poche et michel toulouse les a
rencontrés hier il était à jouy en josas
et il profitait de cette journée de
tourisme un peu inattendu m'expliquer
vos ennuis et pourquoi vous devez par
exemple partir demain aux états unis
alors que vous deviez rester trois mois
ici oui c'était pas trois mois c'était
six semaines que c'était prévu pour nous
c'était trois mois mais c'est que notre
société chez nous nous a envoyé un mot
dimanche soir lundi matin qu'ils ne
peuvent plus donner les logements les
repas les guides les tours tout ça et
que c'est dans l'intérêt de nos
étudiants de retourner aux etats-unis
aussi vite que possible
c'était prévu d'avoir 4500 étudiants ici
cet été je crois qu'il y à 3000 qui sont
déjà ici en europe qui sont comme loïc
l'a fait et toujours pouvoir revenir oui
et est-ce que vous conseille de deux
sociétés étaient sérieuses avant de
partir est ce que vous aviez dévoué et
bien sûr un non pas du tout un nom et
vous croyez qu'elle est la raison qu'il
n'ya pas de l'argent ça doit être la
raison mais je ne sais pas pourquoi
alors il ya 4000 étudiants qui sont un
peu partout en europe où ses 3000 qui
sont à
en europe parce qu'il y a c'était prévu
d'avoir 22 groupes en europe cet écueil
17 je crois sont arrivés donc ça fait
peut-être très 3000 qui sont en italie
en suisse en allemagne ici en france au
chapitre des vacances il nous faut
également signaler l'accident qui a
marqué hier
l'excursion d'une colonie de vacances en
ariège 17 garçons avaient entrepris avec
leur moniteur une promenade dans la
région du lac de bethmale et au moment
où il longea une paroi abrupte une
partie du groupe a glissé il ya
malheureusement un mort et deux blessés
autre accident qui a fait également un
mort mais cette fois en belgique
l'accident de l'express londres cologne
il a déraillé
la nuit dernière près de gand on a eu
très peur cette nuit également wav ou
après un orage particulièrement violent
la foudre s'est abattue sur l'un des
bacs du port pétrolier mettant le feu à
plus de 2000 mètres cubes de produits
inflammables
devant l'ampleur de cet incendie de
nombreux navires parmi lesquels le
france avait reçu l'ordre de se préparer
à parier hatoum fort heureusement les
services de sécurité et les pompiers se
sont rendus maîtres du sinistre et vers
4h15 ce matin on apprenait que tout
danger était écarté
il y à 3 - souvenez-vous très exactement
le 16 avril le sanatorium du rock défi
sur le plateau d'assy était éventrée par
une coulée de terre
on a appris ce matin que le rapport de
la commission denquête commission
denquête désigné par le gouvernement
pour cette catastrophe ne pourra être
rendu public claude carré retrace pour
nous les circonstances de cette
catastrophe et nous dit pourquoi ce
rapport ne sera pas publié en effet on
ne connaîtra pas la teneur de ce rapport
de la commission denquête car il est
maintenant une pièce de justice et comme
tel il ne peut être divulguée pourquoi
une pièce de justice parce que des
rescapés les parents des victimes ont
déposé des plaintes des actions en
justice sont donc ouvertes et ce rapport
est l'un des éléments importants du
dossier de cette tragique catastrophe
souvenez-vous de la nuit du 16 avril
dernier une coulée de boue et de roches
et ensevelissaient 71 personnes dont 56
enfants du sanatorium de rock de fils en
trois jours et trois nuits des centaines
de sauveteurs tentaient de dégager les
corps des malheureuses victimes
un travail acharné gênées par le mauvais
temps mais là sous la boue les blocs de
béton d'une seule
thorium ravagé on ne retrouvait que des
corps sans vie cette catastrophe était
elle prévisible
qui est responsable la justice va
maintenant suivre son cours à l'étranger
aujourd'hui une information en
provenance de bangkok nous apprend que
le premier ministre thaïlandais le
maréchal chitika schorn a mis en état de
pleine alerte toutes les troupes qui
sont stationnés à bangkok et dans les
principales villes thaïlandaise et ce en
raison du climat je cite de tension et
d'insécurité politique qui règne en ce
moment en thaïlande
vous le voyez une affaire à suivre avec
beaucoup d'attention plus près de nous
en italie c'est aujourd'hui que le
président de la république italienne
monsieur joseph peyssard agathe comment
ces consultations pour essayer de
trouver un successeur à monsieur mariano
rumor le premier ministre démissionnaire
depuis avant-hier
cette première phase de consultation de
monsieur sarr agathe s'achèvera à la fin
de la semaine vraisemblablement sant
toujours en europe il faut signaler
aussi la fin du voyage de monsieur
alexis kossyguine et dans les bagages de
monsieur kossyguine qui est rentré ce
matin à moscou un nouveau traité
d'amitié soviéto room gérard ce bac
traité signé par monsieur kossyguine et
morère les deux chefs de gouvernement ne
peut tout de même pas masquer les
divergences de vue entre moscou et
bucarest
un point important qui souligne le
désengagement roumain dans le précédent
traité sur le plan militaire les deux
parties devaient apporter une aide
immédiate à celui qui seraient attaqués
par l'allemagne et ses alliés dans le
nouveau traité le pays victime d'une
agression impérialiste en premier lieu
demandent de l'aide et ensuite des
conversations doivent s'ouvrir pour
savoir si c'était peut lui être fournies
ainsi les roumains n'engage en rien leur
responsabilité dans un éventuel conflit
avec les états unis ou la chine se fêter
ce biais aux roumains rappelle également
les liens étroits et fondamentaux qui
lie les peuples des deux pays et de
toute la communauté socialiste avant de
passer aux sports trois informations à
berchtesgaden deux nouveaux corps ont
été retrouvés deux nouveaux corps de
militaires français ont été découverts
par les sauveteurs dans les débris de
l'hélicoptère de la bundeswehr qui
s'était écrasé mardi dernier après une
manoeuvre ce qui porte à 12 le nombre
des victimes de cette catastrophe douze
victimes dont huit militaires français
ouverture ce matin à aix-en-provence du
procès de puyricard dans une salle
d'audience archi plein 36 témoins et aux
avocats observé par une quarantaine de
journalistes essaieront d'établir la
culpabilité des trois accusés le premier
vous le voyez sur cette photo gaston
causse terrasse 29 ans dit joe l'aixois
sauveur padovani 55 ans à droite et
arlette boulbès 40 2 enfin sachez que ce
matin à aubigny au bac dans le nord
depuis la fin de la matinée un homme de
25 ans monsieur jean guéhenno s'est
enfermé à son domicile avec sa fille est
âgée de 15 mois monsieur guéant nous a
dit qu'il tirait sur quiconque voudrait
lui reprendre sa fillette est pour
l'instant aux dernières nouvelles les
gendarmes essaient d'entrer en
communication avec monsieur guen patrick
chapuis les sports un très beau match
d'athlétisme je crois plus ce soir et
demain colombes c'est un très très grand
match de tennis entre la france et les
états unis
c'est un petit peu david contre goliath
et il ne faut surtout pas aller là-bas
avec l'attention de compter les points
iront là-bas pouvoir pratiquer au plus
haut niveau le plus beau des sports
olympiques le premier sport olympique
d'ailleurs nous allons maintenant
rendez vous des français qui étaient
hier soir réunit les athlètes françaises
sont réunis dans un hôtel au centre de
paris et pierre fulla a interrogé trois
d'entre eux sur leurs ambitions tout
d'abord hervé d'encausse qui revient
très fort à la perche d'encausse
après un an et demi d'absence vous
faites votre retour en équipe de france
comment abordez-vous cette rencontre
savez pour moi cette rencontre bien sûr
est très importante mais disons que
compte tenu des circonstances
et c'est mes possibilités nous abordons
ce match vraiment très décontractés pour
la bonne raison du très peu
d'entraînement harcèlement donc je crois
qu'il faudra compter plusieurs
satellites sur moi
bien sûr je vous raconte les américains
que les actus un 67 pour moi ça serait
une revanche dans le heureusement et que
je voulais dire c'est dans des
conditions tout soit vraiment mauvaise
pour moi mais j'ai serait malgré tout de
faire le maximum pour l'équipe de france
étaient tous ces genres en fait je
connais parce que plus est ce que vous
comptez prendre des risques face à ses
soutes américain l'écouté dans une une
compétition qui va c'est dur je suis
obligé de prendre des risques parce que
j'ai pas une condition extraordinaire
comme si je veux sauter au froid que je
commence donc pour moi prendre des
risques énormes
jean paul villain vous êtes considéré
comme un vainqueur possible de ce france
etats unis
et lorsque l'on analyse vos courses nous
fait généralement la course en tête ce
soir que ferez vous ce soir c'est un peu
difficile pour moi de le dire car
habituellement trop mes courses cela se
décide bien souvent sur la ligne de
départ
j'ai une concentration
en moi et
prend la résolution de partir en tête ou
alors de suivre
l'adversaire est selon comment je me
sens aussi si je me sens très bien
demain soir je prendrai la tête en
essayant de faceo 15 cents sur les bases
de 4 6 4 11 pour tenter peut-être un
record de france
il y aussi ce possible voulez parler du
record du monde qui vient d'être
récemment amélioré par l'australie
ambrian oui j avais songé plus ce soir
j'ai songé bien sûr et j'ai fait mon
tableau de marche sur 8 20 si j'ai la
chance de réussir à bien tant mieux si
ça ne passe pas bien j'espère que les
gens ne liront pas dire il a la grosse
tête ou
on n'est pas capable soit attendre les
je crois qu'il n'y a que des ambitions
qui fait avoir certains résultats
surtout dans l'athlétisme sport
individuel à 100%
pierre colnard le couronnement d'une
carrière exceptionnelle comme la vôtre
puisque je crois que vous avez 41 ans
serait de battre les deux lanceurs
américains
bah disons un américain ça ne suffirait
si je peux les deux naturellement son
ferait plus plaisir
vous avez récemment égalé votre record
de france avec 19 m 57 pensez-vous le
pouvoir l'améliorer cette occasion mais
disons en prenait 19 57 de l'ul j'étais
dans une forme extraordinaire d'ailleurs
j'avais préparé énormément les trois
matches qui auraient c'est à dire les
championnats du monde militaires ou lui
france-amérique éventuellement et les
champions de france et je ne sais pas ce
qui se passe depuis deux trois jours
j'ai eu une décompression je sais plus
où j'en suis disons que le moral sur le
terrain on reviendra peut-être un moral
que l'on connaît bien karpiel corner
s'accroche à chaque essai à disons que
le match qui mais qui me paraît le plus
à coeur ce serait au moins celui ci
comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le faire
c'est peut-être le dernier
alors ça me plairait assez de faire
quelque chose non élites et pierre
konarka 41 encore beaucoup d'ambitions
il a même annoncé qu'il essaierait avant
de se retirer de battre les 20 m au
poids pierre connard été nommé capitaine
de l'équipe de france et la
reconnaissance par tous ses camarades de
cette grande sympathie qui existe autour
de lui les athlètes canadiens eux
préparent déjà les jeux de 1976 qui
auront lieu montréal il ya de créer une
sorte de laboratoire de détection des
qualités chez les athlètes
c'est un reportage de robert saison à
toronto lors il percevait l'ancien
champion de boxe dirige le premier
laboratoire de recherche de sportifs
avant l'épreuve avant le stade la
machine électronique sera si l'athlète
deviendra un jour un champion nous
contribuons ici à la recherche de la
meilleure forme des meilleures
performances pour nos athlètes canadiens
et nous les dirigeons sur la discipline
qui leur convient le mieux
par exemple nancy gré nous avons
constaté que malgré la puissance
exceptionnelle de la musculature de ses
jambes elle était capable d' une
relaxation parfaite en étudiant
scientifiquement son comportement nous
avons pu l'adapter au bénéfice d'autres
skieur de compétition
ceci est également vrai pour même glané
un champion de hockey grâce à lui nous
pouvons déterminer un programme
d'entraînement à l' usage d'autres
sportifs pour développer leur vitesse
leur agilité leur souplesse dans la
pratique du hockey grâce à nos tests
psychologiques et physiques
nous nous rendons compte des
possibilités maximum de nos athlètes et
nous pouvons déterminer à l'avancé si
oui ou non à l'individu a les qualités
requises pour faire un haltérophile où
sera assez rapide pour jouer trois
quarts aile rugby ou tout simplement
pour savoir s'il sera assez souple pour
devenir un gymnase
mais il est plus difficile d'influencer
le comportement psychologique
nous espérons que nous allons contribuer
au succès des équipes canadiennes pour
les jeux olympiques de montréal en 76
football maintenant et de nouvelle
importante
roy envisagerait d'abandonner le
professionnalisme qui permettrait
ajaccio qui vous savez et éliminés de
façon un peu arbitraire de retrouver sa
place en première division
professionnelle également une très bonne
nouvelle
le joueur brésilien jairzinho que nous
avions tous admirer pendant la dernière
coupe du monde viendrait jouer en france
il serait en effet transféré à nice pour
125 millions anciens pelé lui aurait
reçu aussi des propositions assez
impressionnante
on parle même d'un chèque en blanc que
lui aurait envoyé une équipe étrangère
pour prendre la direction de cette
équipe
nous recevons une dépêche maintenant qui
est intéressant toujours en football on
voit déjà se dessiner la saison
prochaine tirage au sort en coupe
d'europe des clubs en 16e de finale de
la coupe d'europe saint-etienne qui
était champion français sera opposé au
champion d'italie
cagliari tour de france pour terminer
12e étape aujourd'hui entre thonon les
bains et grenoble 5 collèges qu'elle a
day avec la très difficile chartreuse en
fait c'est vraiment maintenant le départ
de la montagne le départ des très
difficile étape de montagne j'habitais à
la limite peut-être du sport cette
information patrick chapuis en
provenance de pékin qui nous apprend que
grâce à la pensée du président mao tsé
toung
une équipe de médecins militaires a
réussi à soigner avec succès des gens
atteints de surdité des gens aveugles
voire même des paralysés le communiqué
ajoute que ces malades avait été avant
examinés par des médecins dits bourgeois
et que ces médecins les avait déclarés
incurable j'espère que la bourse ne sera
quand même pas besoin de la médecine
chinoise
jean-michel quatre points rassuré nous
tout de suite sur la santé des valeurs
françaises et étrangères à vous la
bourse vient vous savez la bourse est
anémique et en fait elle ne sait plus à
quels saints ou plutôt à quel docteur se
vouer les bonnes et les mauvaises
nouvelles se succèdent et en fait elle
ça nulle si bien que la bourse
aujourd'hui est stable et que les écarts
sont à de rares exceptions près très
faible en ce qui concerne les aspects
positifs
monsieur giscard d'estaing a annoncé
hier en quelque sorte la sortie du plan
de redressement
le ministre des finances a déclaré que
le 1er juillet
avait marqué le passage d'une politique
de rétablissement des équilibres à une
politique d'accompagnement de la
croissance en clair cela veut dire que
l'on va relancer l'expansion en
stimulant la consommation
monsieur giscard d'estaing accorde donc
à la ménagère le droit d'acheter et je
cite ces propos la consigne de non achat
de la machine à laver est désormais levé
ces propos la bourse et a bien accueilli
mais dans le même temps gouvernement a
annoncé cette relance de l'expansion un
avis a été publié ce matin au journal
officiel avis qui aux yeux de nombreux
boursier allait à l'encontre des mesures
de desserrement des contraintes
les banques vont en effet être obligées
d'augmenter leurs coefficients de
réserves obligatoires
cette mesure mérite quelques
explications les banques sont tenues de
garde et encaissent un certain volume
d'argent liquide
ainsi en simplifiant les choses une
banque qui avait 100 millions de formes
dépôt devait garder six millions et demi
en argent gelé
c'est à dire qu'elles ne pouvaient
utiliser cette somme tout le reste est
le prêter ou l'investisseur depuis ce
matin cette banque sera obligée de geler
7 millions et en obligeant ainsi les
établissements bancaires à garder plus
d'argent liquide ont restreint bien
évidemment le volume de crédits qu'ils
peuvent accorder
parallèlement le taux d'intérêt maximum
pour les prêts d'argent a été porté de
18 vient de 0 8% contre 2 pardon a été
porté à 18,0 8% contre 17,14 %
précédemment
l'argent vous le voyez est donc de plus
en plus cher alors la bourse ne sait
plus très bien quelle attitude adopter
surtout que les nouvelles de l'étranger
ne sont pas encourageantes
wall street a encore perdu près de 7
points hier et la plupart des milieux
financiers mondiaux craignent un été
chaud sur le plan monétaire bull bull
est un des gros points noirs de la cote
le titre a perdu 6% hier et depuis la
dernière liquidation le repli s'inscrit
à 15 %
cette baisse risque d'avoir des
conséquences sur l'augmentation de
capital qui est prévue pour le mois de
septembre aux valeurs étrangères
les allemandes sont stables montrent
même bayer qui gagne 6 francs 8 francs
derrière nous allons voir un tableau
fixe
l'étrangère vous voyez si mal gagne 5
francs 20 n'a pas dit si francs general
motors 24 ans 58 et et se replie encore
et à café depuis longtemps le cours des
200 francs vous voyez à peu près les
replis sont de faible ampleur la csa tu
perds 10 centimes pechiney pechiney perd
60 centimes décennies par contre gan
quatre ans 60 allons voir un peu plus
loin à ugine kuhlmann qui s'était bien
tenu qu'à ces dernières bourse
kevin
usine puis vannes n'est pas encore coté
minutes il se tient pas mal la société
qui a changé de président monsieur
grézels a remplacé en effet monsieur
jolivet donc la société envisage de
construire une nouvelle aciérie à
fos-sur-mer
avec une capacité de production de
l'ordre de 600 mille tonnes d'acier
sécuriser les investissements sont
bienveillantes très important on parle
de 650 millions de francs
ils seront vraisemblablement assurée
grâce à un emprunt obligataire d'un
montant de 500 me je prends le reste les
tentations et par l'autofinancement sur
le marché de l'or on note des achats sur
le lingot 6415 contre 6390 hier les
pièces par contre reste lui stable opiné
opiné le premier coup et est en baisse
de 20 centimes on côté 158 francs 20
contre 158 40 hier mais je crois que
derrière on a regagné 20 centimes
oui effectivement répète le cours d'hier
158 francs 40 donc le kiné et un échange
et c'était la bourse de paris a ouvert
en pire qui tarde merci jean michel 4
points une dernière chose à vous
rappeler c'est aujourd'hui qu'a commencé
l'opération vignette elle a commencé
d'abord dans la région parisienne et je
vous rappelle que vous devrez montrer
patte blanche et vignettes à tous ceux
qui sont susceptibles de vous demander
cette vignette si par hasard si par
mégarde vous n'avez pas votre vignette
sur vous vous aurez 24 heures pour
prouver votre bonne foi alors en
espérant bien sûr que cette mégarde ne
vous arrivera pas je vous souhaite je
vous remercie d'abord pour votre
attention et avec toute l'équipe de télé
midi je vous souhaite une excellente
après-midi
m